welcome to episode 31 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i spoke with dr jill
krista
dr krista is the author of break the
mold a toxic mold specialist
and an international educator for mold
treatment we spoke about the very
serious effects of toxic mold including
the symptoms and potential long-term
illnesses
related to mold infections how to test
your body for mold sickness
how to remove mold from your home and
the illnesses related to mold infections
i wanted to delve into mold a bit
because sometimes when you have a
disorder and you're trying to figure out
the root cause you have to go down
every alley however unlikely for my
autoimmune and mood disorder and
plethora of other lovely health
disorders
it was mainly diet which was causing
inflammation
gut damage food proteins were leaking
into my body
and triggering an immune response i had
overgrowths we've got bacteria and fungi
from
said diet etc probably lyme disease
didn't help with all that
mold toxicity can lead to a ton of
different symptoms
and some people are certainly more
susceptible to mold than others although
nobody is immune
i hope this episode is helpful this is
my last episode filmed in serbia from
june
i took a bit of a break when i got home
from the craziness of the last year and
i just started recording again last week
this friday i'll be releasing an episode
with none other than matthew mcconaughey
i'm still demonetized from youtube for
some reason probably because i had
covered and didn't die
so i'm seriously thankful to the
sponsors i've had for helping me
continue
this episode is brought to you by true
local i've been using true local for a
couple of years and they're my go-to
source for meat at home in canada
i get two to three boxes a month what
they do is they partner with local
farmers and butchers in your area in
canada to source some of the best meat
like 100 grass-fed and grass-finished
beef
pasture-raised chicken raised without
antibiotics
lamb buffalo and over 100 different cuts
of meat that you can't find at your
grocery store
you build your own personalized box that
will give you enough meat for the month
or for me for you know a week and a half
or two weeks
with only the products you want and it
shows up at your door
i'm actually working with them to
produce a michaela peterson box so stay
tuned for that
i find that a bit funny who would have
thought i'd have a meat box
oh my god people are gonna bother me
about that anyway i'm very appreciative
that i can get sustainably and locally
raised meat to my door
and it's a great way to support the
local economy by shopping with smaller
farms butchers and suppliers they need
the help right now
so if you've been thinking about giving
them a shot they're totally worth it
their lamb is amazing use the code mp
to get two free rib eyes with your order
and to show them you came from here
if you like this episode please rate it
and subscribe tell a friend and if you
hate it
just go away and don't join the one star
reviews i have from my vegan or auntie
peterson crowd
now let's learn about mold
[Music]
dr krista welcome to my podcast thanks
for having me it's a real treat to be
here
so i'd like to start off just if you
could give a bit of a background about
who you are and what it is that you do
so my audience can get to know you a bit
yeah i am a naturopathic doctor which
means i'm trained
i'm a medically trained natural medicine
doctor
so i practice in wisconsin which tends
to be
a hotbed of environmental illnesses and
lyme disease so i was working in private
practice
seeing families in my community and
realizing that i have i was having
struggle with some patients that weren't
responding and they
ended up having lyme disease and i
wasn't really
i didn't understand what that meant you
know the the broad ramifications of
having lyme
so i became a lyme expert and generally
when you
apply the principles of naturopathic
medicine people get better
because people that come to see me as a
doctor if you're coming to a
naturopathic doctor you know you're
going to get homework
you're going to get diet changes
lifestyle changes all of these things
so most of my patients fared pretty well
but there's this group
even with the lyme disease treatment on
board that weren't getting better
and in one of those patients homes they
found black mold
and that started this whole journey for
me on i wonder if that's what's going on
with this guy and
i wonder if that's what's going on with
these other people that aren't
responding and i became a mold expert
so that took me into the world of
treating people with the complex chronic
conditions autoimmune diseases
neuroinflammatory diseases like pandas
and pans
my kids also have pandas and so i kind
of became the doctor that
all the weird conditions you know that
i would handle all of that and because i
love it i love to dig and i love to see
people
improve that we're given no hope that
they were going to ever
see normal life again and that's
that was my passion and now we had mold
in my own home a couple years ago
and i thought and it was while i was
doing i was taping a course an online
course for doctors
to train them on mold illness and this
all happened while i was
taping that course so it was very
strange that all of a sudden i had a
flood in my house
and i thought what is that about there's
got to be some message there
and once i realized that we were being
sick from mold
the flood kind of revealed itself and i
thought oh my goodness this has been
mold all along
and i'm a mold specialist and i missed
it happening to myself
i have to write a book because i knew
exactly what to do once i found out it
was mold
i kicked in gear my protocols i knew how
to help my family
and i thought this is and none of it is
rocket science
you know it's something that everybody
can do so i thought i need to write a
book about this and
trying to take what i know out to the
world because one doctor can only see so
many people
so that's that's my background in short
cool okay that's really cool i didn't
know that you were a lyme expert as well
which bodes very well for me because i
tested positive for lyme
um a couple of years ago i was i'd had
extremely severe arthritis like
disintegrated two of my joints i have
two joints
replaced and so i got tested for lyme
um through a hospital in toronto when i
was seven and it became back negative
um i grew up in boston before that
and then i retested through a different
company in the states
a couple of years ago and it came back
positive and i thought maybe that was an
explanation for the arthritis
so i can throw a whole bunch of
questions at you for sure
um starting with like i know
from what i've done the research behind
lime there are a lot of people who can
get lyme disease and they don't get that
sick right right um
so is it do you have any idea
what makes some people more susceptible
to these things or why
some people can get hit with lyme or
with mold toxicity and then end up
being incredibly ill and why some people
can just live in a house with mold and
not necessarily be as affected
sure you know this is why i went into
natural medicine because it isn't
singular mechanism there's no single
thing to answer that question the most
obvious thing that medicine looks at
with lime is which strain did you get
infected with
how much of the bacteria did you get
with that bite that makes a really big
difference
yeah same thing with any kind of thing
like hpv
there's the dangerous strains and
there's the not so dangerous strains
so that's that's the first thing that we
would look at is just basically
did you get a more virulent strain or if
someone got a more virulent strain
they're going to have more suffering and
more problems with the disease people
that get
more of a bacterial load when they get
that bite have a harder time
and then that's the stuff about the bug
and then there's the stuff about the
terrain of the body
so then we have you know pre-existing
conditions
nutrient status do you know someone
exercising are they sedentary
are they full of antioxidants are they
really inflamed and so there are lots of
things like that
and then the age at which the person got
the infection
you know how resilient are you are you
able to
um you know as a kid you can kind of
bounce back from things and
um i also think that kids don't
necessarily bounce back they just don't
feel like they can complain
so we miss a we miss a lot in kids or
they don't even
they don't know any different so what
like why complain if that's just
what your life is like right um okay so
i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna focus on lime for this
episode because i was prepared to learn
about mold
but yeah sure i might have to have you
back on to delve into lime so we'll see
um i think the main place to start with
mold is why should why should anybody
care
to know about mold like what's the point
of learning about mold
that's a great question yeah because
if you it were to ask anyone that
doesn't know about the hazards of mold
on health they would say oh it's just
kind of an aesthetic problem
it just makes it things look ugly just
paint over it you know
the problem with that is yeah mold makes
these toxins
they're called mycotoxins and they are
they're designed for the mold to defend
its territory
so once a mold spore finds what i call
lakefront property like it only has to
be a little bit of humidity
like an air conditioning filter it
doesn't have to be a flood
and that's the problem that people don't
really understand just has to be enough
humidity to feed it
once it finds that territory it wants to
hold that
property with its life
so it will create these toxins to gas
bomb out
all the other mold species or bacteria
or whatever is in the environment
including humans pets any living thing
gets that toxin so we aren't we aren't
really the intended target of those
toxins
but we are affected by them and that's
why people need to care
is that you have a if you have a happily
growing mold in your indoor environment
it's sending all of these toxins into
the air which is now poisoning your air
so as you breathe you're getting this
toxic poison that's
designed as a bio weapon and
now militaries around the world have
picked up on this and they are actually
creating mycotoxin biowarfare
so and i have people that say mold
doesn't bother me
i'm like if it didn't we wouldn't be
making
biowarfare out of it so it's a it's a
matter of dose duration
and susceptibility so it just scary
completely i know it's
terrifying yeah
that's why people should care yeah okay
um so what are the symptoms
well what are some of the main symptoms
of mold toxicity and how do you tell
that that's specifically
mold toxicity and not a bacterial
infection or a viral problem or an
autoimmune
problem yeah that's the big dilemma
then i can give you kind of the main
picture of someone who's
been sick from mold and you can get sick
from just the toxins so if that mold is
behind building materials
the toxins come right through the
building materials it comes through
insulation drywall flooring
anything it can come right through those
because they're ultra small
some people are also exposed to the
spore so they're going to have
spore based kind of allergies asthma
hay fever that kind of thing so that's
what we kind of define
as mold illness is mold allergy but i am
on a mission to expand that definition
to mold toxicity
to get those mycotoxins in there because
in my personal
practice probably 75 of the people i'm
seeing
are mycotoxic not mold allergic
so um so the symptoms then can be
spore based like i just said you know
hay fever sinusitis
sore throat post nasal drip asthma
allergies that kind of look the other
70ish percent
is going to be toxin based and these
toxins are nerve toxic
they're immune toxic they're toxic to
our gut lining
our skin to our genes
and to our brain and nervous system so
now that i've said that you can imagine
it could create almost any symptom in
the body depending on what your
pre-existing
achilles heel is yeah but the most
common is fatigue
and that can look like debilitating
fatigue or that can look like somebody
who's an athlete
who has a low vo2 max so it just depends
on where we're starting from on that
when they
begin to be exposed to the mold but
people
generally describe just a level of
things are a little harder than
they should be or than they used to be
before they took that new job or moved
into that new apartment or whatever
so fatigue is a big one also anxiousness
so i don't think i have had any patient
um and i'm scanning in my mind right now
that
hasn't reported some sort of internal
angst and it's not necessarily i'm
careful not to say anxiety because that
conjures up like anxiety disorders and
you know needing medication and that
kind of thing
certainly that can happen but it's more
of
it can even be subtle it can be an inner
sense of
unrest an inner sense that things aren't
okay and that that's because things
aren't okay you're breathing a
poison you know so it's your body being
really smart
um gut problems are very very common so
having like a irritable bowel syndrome
alternating constipation diarrhea
constipation bloating
sort of a candida overgrowth look a lot
of people that are mold toxic do also
get candida overgrowth because the body
is now
sort of having an over fungal burden so
it can't control the other
fungi in the body and keep him in chat
that's so gross
yeah yeah then you might see skin rashes
um uh so let's see gut skin
brain anxious foggy mind brain fog
um and then frequent infections so
even if you're not exposed to spores
these are going to be the people that
once they get a cold even if they're not
dealing with like pros nasal drip all
the time or sinusitis all the time
they get colds a lot and when they do
they tend to either linger or
turn into bacterial infections or like a
chronic
bacterial vaginosis or chronic uti
some of the oddities of mold are ear
ringing
and if you think about that one of the
the main drug classifications that
causes ear ringing is antibiotics
and a lot of antibiotics are mold toxin
you know their
penicillium species of mold makes
penicillin
the mycotoxin so you know that makes
sense that a lot of people will feel
like they
they have a lot of earrings when they're
in their mold exposure and
that can be the hardest one to actually
cure
that usually is a lingering symptom for
people somewhat
yeah and the other one is interstitial
cystitis that's another oddity
pelvic pain pelvic region pain
then i go looking now i go looking at
mold but as i'm saying these things
you're thinking well that could be
it could be anything it could be adrenal
fatigue food allergies
lyme disease all these things so in
practice i created a questionnaire
because i was seeing a lot of lyme
disease patients and i was having a hard
time
they both look so similar i couldn't
tell
to save time you know so that we didn't
have to go down the track of
treat everybody for lyme and then if
they didn't get better now treat them
for mold
yeah so i tried to create this clinical
questionnaire that
started to discern which of those
symptoms are more mold
and which of those symptoms are more
lime and dr horowitz richard horowitz
who's
a genius and one of our lime experts has
been able to identify that lime has
migration so there's going to be a joint
pain
of your right knee and then it's your
first finger on the left side you know i
mean it could migrate all over that's
kind of a keynote for lime
mold doesn't do that so i took that off
the questionnaire and then i created my
own questionnaire that gives you sort of
a score
so if anybody is interested in that i
have the if you're a practitioner
listening
i have that questionnaire they can just
email me through my website
and they can get that questionnaire to
start using in clinic because it really
saves you time
it just gets down to okay it gives you a
score of
nope not mold possibly mold probable
mold so which way is that needle moving
and then you can further investigate
with testing and things like that
and if anybody's listening and just
wants to take i have
a quiz online moldquiz.com and it it's
very educational so
just be warned it's easy to take
you don't have to do the reading i i
have reading about you know why this
symptom
what is it about mold that's creating
that symptom but it's been you know a
lot of people are like wow i learned so
much just by taking your quiz and it was
so interesting to
to hear that it it might be mold and i
never even considered it
yeah okay that's that's fascinating i'm
gonna check that out
um so then my next question would be how
do you confirm that it's mold
how do you test that yeah so to just
treat or are there specific tests you do
you know
sometimes we will just treat if we know
there's been a mold exposure and there
answer the questionnaire and it shows
possible or probable mold
we save the money on testing and we just
get right to the treatment
but if somebody is if we don't know
what's going on
and they've answered the questionnaire
and it's a possible mold
then we need to do some more
investigation because that also means
it might be where they're working it
might be where they live and that's a
whole other secondary investigation so
we need some
security that it's mold so i will use a
whole litany of tests that really
depends on the person and what else they
have going on
if they have insurance coverage but one
of the tests i use a lot is a urine
mycotoxin test
and that's a way to you know if you're
kind of to take people through why would
that be a good test like if you're
breathing
in the toxins that gets into your lung
tissue which goes to your bloodstream
and then your kidneys filter your blood
so it's a good way to kind of catch if
the person is being exposed to mold and
mycotoxins
the tricky part about that is there's
two tricks we don't know if you're
testing positive for mold
if that was an exposure you had 10 years
ago
because the mold will actually move into
your body so that's what's kind of
wild you could have a positive urine
test
with exposure from old 10 years ago yeah
it has happened because it's just
growing uh that's horrible yeah so when
my theory and this could be the wrong
theory but this is the theory i use to
develop my protocol
is that when you get exposed to those
toxins in the air
your own flora senses that something's
trying to invade
and so it starts acting defensively and
spitting out their own toxins and
defending their territory
yeah over time that can lead to
you know you go basically from getting
the outside poison and now you're
poisoning yourself
and now your immune system gets hit at
your mucus lining and then the mold
moves into your sinuses in your gut
because there's now it's just like an
inflamed war zone
so there's this kind of continuum of of
illness so if somebody has gotten down
to the end continuums especially like
kids who are raised in a moldy basement
like their bedroom was in a moldy
basement
they are so colonized by that moldy
building
that they're carrying it with them all
through their life
and it's amazing like you have somebody
in their
mid-20s or something and we're treating
them for mold and they're no longer
in mold so you also have to do the
building examination
um so and we start trading them for mold
and it's like oh my gosh
i didn't realize that i could jog you
know i've never been able to keep up
with my
siblings or my you know whatever so it's
just it's really neat to see
oh wow yeah that's brutal um one of the
it's in like my assumption for people
with i talk to a lot of people with
autoimmune disorders
and my assumption and i have i could
totally be off but i would assume that
most people with autoimmune disorders
have something their bodies fighting
against that's what i
feel is right right something maybe a
virus may be bacteria i didn't really
think about
mold past candida but something
irritated them and their body is
constantly fighting it
and that fight is destroying their
tissues um
and that's what i like believe happened
to me and
somehow the carnivore diet stopped that
um
so that's so what do you do for those
people
like how do you help people who've been
colonized
forever or people who are who are
breathing it and obviously they have to
get rid of the mold so i guess that's
two questions one
what do you do to someone who's been
previously colonized and they no longer
have an active
like living in a mold situation i treat
all of them about the same
i mean that the oh and i should go back
on the ear and mycotoxin test we can
talk about the the second thing which is
if you are positive on mycotoxins you
may be you may be eating them
in your food source although that tends
to be
a distraction that insurance companies
are trying to introduce into the
conversation
so that we can they don't have to pay
for people to get their place
oh nice okay so yeah so what i do is i
take
um the typical mycotoxin contaminated
foods
i have a little prep sheet that i give
my patients before we run that urine
mycotoxin test
and it just says for three days just
don't eat these foods and they tend to
be like grains
mushrooms corn things that are stored
grown into higher quantity stored get
moldy
and then can get mycotoxin contamination
so i have them just go off of those so
we've really limited
that argument and then we can say okay
you know anything we're seeing
is likely it's in the body you are
dealing with it we just don't know if
it's coming from your building
your current built space or from a past
exposure and that's what we have to suss
out with building
so i just want to make sure that i
people are like you said there were two
things we only talked about the one and
i knew i would get a lot of emails about
that so if i didn't go
circle back um yeah would
would aged meat or coffee be on that
list of foods to avoid
coffee is definitely i mean if you're
using something like a bulletproof like
a
it's verified and micro toxin-free i
have no problem with it
um and then meat is like the the
pastramis and the
um prosciutto and things that definitely
needs to come and that's not on my list
interestingly enough
i should put it on there because most
people are eating
the grains the grains yeah that's a
bigger
yeah that's um but i should add that
because yes of course those meats are
they're purposefully moldy like they're
it it's the flavor it's like cheese you
know it's a
put a little mold on it makes it taste
better so yeah that's
it's possible that those are
mycotoxin-laden foods as well you bet
um interesting so you had asked what do
i do
for these people um number one is
avoidance
and they have to get away from the mold
exposure
so a lot of attention goes to where is
this coming from
is this in my current exposure most of
the time it's going to be in their
current exposure
it's a rare case where i have somebody
who is testing positive and it's from
something
a long long time ago most of the time
there's something
in their space either they brought multi
furniture with them from that other
space
or they're in a moldy environment if
they're previously sensitized and have
been made sick by mold a long time ago
it only takes a tiny bit then it could
be an occupational
you know maybe their office building
they have a moldy problem in the
bathroom or something like that and that
can be enough to set
things off again um so i
the my approach is definitely and that's
consistent with all mold training
doctors
is get them away from the mold you know
people aren't going to get better if
they're in that exposure
go back to thinking about biowarfare you
know like that
you're not going to get better and with
your your
theory about the autoimmune disease you
know we know that about certain
autoimmune diseases are linked to
certain
infections so we can say okay a cocksack
eb
infection is linked to you know this and
this autoimmune disease so there are
certain things like that and i think
you're absolutely right
i think there's also congenital
exposures
and there's this whole interesting
generational thing that can happen with
immune systems
so um you know like in my personal case
i had lyme disease and didn't know it
and gave it to my kids in utero
and then they developed lyme disease and
autoimmune disease so i think it
sometimes can be a generational kind of
thing
so i do a lot of on that note a lot of
immune support
and this is going to go counter to what
what your diet is
i put people on a ton of fruits and
vegetables
because i feel like they're not getting
these enough of the bioflavonoids that
have been shown in animal studies
to protect them from the effects of
those mycotoxins
we have learned that each color band of
the rainbow in food
will confer some amount of
mold specific effect so like resveratrol
which is like a deep blue purple color
that one protects the brain and the
nervous system and the heart and
cardiovascular
so if there are certain areas that a
person is really struggling i'll try to
target a certain color band
for them so like greens folic acid
that's going to be
protecting the genes protecting
methylation all that kind of thing
so part of my protocol is put people on
tons of veggies
but now you know i think that what's
interesting that you're bringing to the
conversation is how much of those are
already pre-metabolized
if you're eating meat you know are you
actually getting it in a more
metabolized or active
way that you can absorb that nutrient
and i don't
i don't know because i haven't studied
it i'll be honest with you i've studied
though
what do they give animals to protect
from mold that's as far as i've gone but
so that's a big part of my protocol is
that fruits and veggies and mostly
veggies because a lot of people
are fruitarians that are sick with mold
because it's feeding the sugar is
feeding the mold and feeding the yeast
feed feed feed yeah so i'm like one
one serving of fruit a day and then the
rest need to be veggies and we try to go
for five to seven servings of veggies a
day
but again really as i've gotten caught
up on your podcast and
what you're doing with your diet it's
really started this this thought process
for me of like
you know well maybe you're getting them
metabolized
in a in a different form i don't know
it's really hard to it's really hard to
tell like my
first my assumption right now is um
for people who have a lot of gut damage
vegetables are harder on the gut
than meat it's mainly absorbed in the
small intestine it's pretty easy if
if you have intestinal surgery a lot of
those doctors will put you on a low
fiber diet just so you absorb all that
and so i think a lot of people with gut
damage benefit from going from cutting
the
fiber and then theoretically they should
be able to heal
and then go back to something that's
more of a regular diet that would be my
assumption
in practice you know i was a primary
care doctor for a lot of years treating
gut problems and things like that i
would always take my patients off raw
food
raw vegetables when they were in a flame
state everything had to be souped
stewed you know canned that kind of
thing just because
it like you said it just rips up an
inflamed gut and that's completely
different than my colleagues you know
most my colleagues are like no they need
the enzymes of raw but i'm like well
just
from my observation in inflamed gut and
raw vegetables
don't get along it causes more suffering
gas bloating
you know all the pain yeah yeah well
pressure cooking just pressure cooking
gets rid of a lot of the
the like lectins or things that can be
inflammatory
so that makes sense uh okay that's
fascinating so do you tell people to cut
anything from their diet other than
reduce so you reduce the amount of sugar
because that could be feeding
the molds is there anything else yeah oh
yeah
um so i have the 10 best and worst foods
for maldives is what i call it and you
can get
that off my website i know people are
like oh
don't call me a moldy but i'm like i
just stopped out of my mouth i can't
help it you know i've got my limeys and
my moldies and
yeah so so yeah i definitely have foods
that i have people focus on eating but
also foods to not
eat so that whole idea of like the body
now
the building is moving into your body
your body now has a fungal burden
so things that are in the fungal family
or things that are going to help that
grow those are the things i take people
off of and then mycotoxin contaminated
foods or frequently mycotoxin
contaminated foods
yeah so that would be you know sugar of
course baked goodies and
especially things made with yeast so
yeasted foods that can make someone go
from
a normal belly to looking pregnant in
like
hours it's amazing i do take people off
kombucha
things like that even though those are
technically bacterially fermented
those do add to that fungal burden in
the body
and you know i again get kickback from
some of my colleagues as they're like
what are you talking about kombucha's
the perfect thing so they're using it
but
personally for me and my experience with
my patient base and maybe that's because
they many had lime also kombucha just
flared things so take people off alcohol
and just straight up sugar sugars and
that's not i'm not a
you know 100 percent all-or-nothing kind
of person i'm a realist
so if you need some honey to kind of
make sure that your
whatever gets down you know that your
remedy gets down that's fine
you know i mean we we have we have other
tools
and so you had asked what do i do for
these people it's very different from my
protocol
is that i use anti-fungals and that
isn't necessarily
typically done in mold treatment but
again i'm going off my theory that the
body gets
invaded by the building you now have a
fungal burden
whether or not you have actually frank
fungal
symptoms like athlete's foot or
jock itch or candida vaginitis
that you don't have to be that far to
benefit from the antifungals
and because i'm using plants i don't
have to wait for somebody to be sick
enough to
kind of warrant or validate the need for
a pharmaceutical drug
because pharmaceutical drugs have high
risk factors
but plants have this whole broad
mechanism of action
so they're most anti-fungal plants are
also antibacterial
most are also anti-inflammatory most are
also
immune modulatory so they're boosting up
that immune system
so antifungals are a very key part of
the way that i approach this
whether or not somebody is actually
fungally infected or not
and i'll use that as a whole body i do
two versions
whole body antifungals and then sinus
antifungals
because if this is your first interface
with that sick building this is going to
be the
tissue that's going to need the most
help resetting
back into like a microbiome a sinu biome
cool so would that be that'd be
substances like oregano oil
yep absolutely yeah
powder arco holy basil thyme
um you know a lot of them that we have
in our spice drawers we've we've
ingested these on purpose
we've added these to our diets on
purpose for eons
and it's because they are beneficial and
i always
i say just because they're common
doesn't mean they're not powerful
we have this sort of normalization
weakening idea in our minds
but cloves cinnamon thyme sage oregano
they're all incredible rosemary i mean
they're incredible and my favorite for
especially for pregnant patients because
a lot of the plants you have to be
careful if someone's pregnant yeah
and little babies you know low fetuses
are the most at risk
to being exposed for mold because the
type the toxins actually
activate in the uterus they can get
right through the placenta and they'll
actually become more nerve toxic
so i do wonder how many i know it's
horrible
so i love to use garlic because it's so
beneficial for pregnant women it's
and it helps them with all the
circulatory things that happen when
you're pregnant the sign
sinuses get swollen when you're pregnant
and garlic's just wonderful
for and again we would think garlic
really you know that's a food that
how is that powerful but it's extremely
powerful
and tastes powerful
[Laughter]
so okay that's all fascinating
information um
i'm fascinated anyway but have you had
patients with autoimmune disorders or
like severe health problems and it
turned out their one
problem was mold yes
yeah um how common is it
i don't know that that's an interesting
question that i just asked myself
i don't know how common that is but
absolutely that when you find
this person that has been breaking one
one system at a time just breaking and
breaking you know just
everything seems to be going the wrong
way like i had a patient who
had a cancer diagnosis because mold is
these toxins are carcinogenic
so he had a cancer diagnosis that was
supposed to be
kind of reminds me of your mom's story
you know like oh it's not going to be a
problem
this is you know he was supposed to end
up in the you know 95 percent of people
this isn't a problem it never progresses
blah blah blah
ended up on the wrong side of the
statistics somehow ended up in that you
know three to five percent category
again and again and again at the same
time has
ear ringing pelvic pain irritable bowel
syndrome and i mean this person we're
he's doing everything right by the books
and it's like why
what is going on and then started to
have joint breakdown
so collagen all these mycotoxins they
get in the way of protein synthesis
so that means like heme which carries
oxygen around in our blood so you can
see people get kind of anemic
you can see collagen and elastin start
to break down
we'll see the proteins that we use a lot
so
it's sort of like when people go through
chemo they have certain symptoms like
gut skin
hair we'll see that with mold too
because that's what these toxins are
doing they're getting in the way of the
synthesis of these proteins
and it's going to show up in rapidly
dividing cells faster than others
so over time though the body kind of
figures that out and
sort of creates compensatory mechanisms
and then the joints kind of they get
robbed so
the bone marrow and the joints kind of
get robbed so that the guts can work and
so that
other things can work um so then this
person started having you know he'd
step off the curb and sprain his ankle
and i'm like
what you know like this you're eating
the perfect diet
you're doing all the exercise you're
supposed to do it doesn't make any sense
and then it came down to
to mold and it was just phenomenal
watching his gray hair come back to
black his
joints clear up pelvic pain reduce ear
ringing reduce that was the one stubborn
one we couldn't ever completely get rid
of
is ear ringing so i'm failing on that
one but you know
all these other things like his gut
firmed up his weight came up
ended up now on the right side of the
statistics with the cancer diagnosis i
mean it's just
amazing so yeah and i see that with
autoimmune disease like rheumatoid
arthritis there's a lot
of rheumatoid arthritis that is a lime
mold combination
definitely that's fascinating
um so anyone listening who has issues
definitely
looking to mold to at least rule it out
if you have
an incurable illness um that's cool
okay so if someone has a house say
how do you and you can't find the mold
are there tests you can
do to rule out mold without seeing
having it visible
oh yeah yeah and that's usually when i
turn to experts in
building stuff people that have spent
their life's work on buildings because
just like people every building is an
individual
so you know it's not necessarily like oh
just do an ermey or you just do this
it's going to be something that i think
you need to have an expert there just
like you would need a doctor
to come and take a look because it's
it's serious enough you know i mean
again i just reiterate for people
this is biowarfare you know these
chemicals are used as biowarfare they're
carcinogenic
they cause birth defects they cause
problems in the body it's not worth just
kind of winging it and getting one of
those little plates at like a big box
store and
and think that that's really giving you
the picture that you need
those little plates are informative like
if you are growing out
a lot of mold that tells you something
but they don't
they don't grow out the indoor toxic
molds they only grow out ten percent of
the indoor toxic molds
so those little plates aren't really
like that's
not a sufficient look at a building so i
generally rely on building experts
certified building biologists mold
inspectors that kind of thing
they help you with so many things they
know where to look
and they will help defend you either
with your your workspace or your
landlord or you know they're there as
your advocate
so just like your doctor for your body i
would say get a a building expert
i can tell the um certifying um
credentials that i would look for if you
think that would be helpful for people
yeah that could be helpful
okay so bbec so that's beau biology
institute
a c a c and i i
c r c so if they have a certification
from any of those
certifying bodies this is somebody who
really knows what they're doing
i would rely on them okay um
so say have you had any clients or
patients
that tested negative in the urine
mycotoxin
test but still had a mold issue yes
absolutely the urine mycotoxin test has
its limitations
uh it's an excretion test meaning the
person has to be strong enough
to show us that that's what's going on
typically i will if i have any question
at all i will run a glutathione
test first to see if they are strong
enough and then
the amounts of glutathione are high
enough for me to actually get an
accurate mycotoxin test
and i might look at other things like
their kidney health on a regular
chem panel and i'm looking at their
immune health on a cbc
so you know the urine mycotoxin is one
data point of a bigger set
so that i can get a good picture so if i
have somebody who
and i say okay how do you do when you go
into target
how do you do if you're too close why
why do you mention target
target is one of the stinkiest faces i
hate
target target walmart i would i assumed
it was the fluorescent lighting like i
go in there and
in eight minutes i can't see i was like
i hate the lighting in here
costco so why did you mention target
yeah
target just because that's for me one of
the most
stinky big box stores and it's probably
because they're just moving so much
product here and it's all new
and sprayed so that or the um
at a regular grocery store but the aisle
where all the
laundry detergent is or the cleaning
solutions if somebody says oh i avoid
that
or um you know or i avoid target or
i avoid driving too close behind another
car because the exhaust bothers me
that's someone who's probably going to
not be
able to show me what their real
microwaxing load is
you just named it all the irritations in
in my life
and i'm gonna i'm gonna guess no candles
no nothing smelly no my husband did like
on
one of our first dates he filled his
like apartment with these red smelly
candles and i came and was like
get them out sorry i know that like this
isn't great
for like a second date but i'm really
allergic to those
yeah yeah yeah so in that case if you
were my patient i would run a
glutathione test
first to see are you even going to be
showing me that
the what your burden is of mycotoxins
you know you might end up
being those one of those people that you
do the test and it just shows up
you know negative there's a lot of
controversy right now over whether to
provoke
for that test or not so sometimes we
might have someone sit in a sauna the
day before
or vigorously exercise if they're able
to the night before because
we help flush everything out
yeah but i think that it's kind of a
tricky
there are some that say i always do it
this way and
i always look at the patient in front of
me because there
what if you have them do a sauna the day
before and they're a really fast
metabolizer
and then they do the urine mycotoxin
test in the morning and their mycotoxins
are cleaned out
overnight they you know whatever so it's
it's a little
it's a little i don't know we we want
the labs to be doing some more testing
big population tests so we can kind of
get a standard of care but we don't have
that right now
but i just look at every patient as an
individual and then we we go from there
which doesn't help any listening because
they're like wait but what about me
yeah yeah well i know these things are
very complicated so is it possible just
to pay
devil's advocate is it possible say you
have a patient
and they test negative for a mold toxin
but they have some of these symptoms
and you treat them with an anti-mold
protocol is it possible that you could
be treating a bacterial infection and
the anti-mold protocol just treats that
absolutely
yeah it's possible yep and the way that
i look at it
is that when you have the exposure to
those mycotoxins
and by the way mold also metabolizes
happily growing mold also metabolizes
all these other things
vocs aldehydes alcohols
i mean they're all part of this indoor
air thing the
the mycotoxins are the most dangerous
the other ones are things that are going
to
increase your chemical load so a lot of
people could become chemically sensitive
just from that part so you might have
somebody who
or i might have somebody who's maybe
they're testing negative on urine
mycotoxin but they're
they truly look mold sick it could be
because their intimate partner is the
one who is the moldy building now
and i've had that happen on a couple
occasions where the
partner who was sick with mold because
every inhalation they were inhaling
mycotoxins from their own sinuses
every exhalation was breathing on the
partner while they slept
and that's gonna make people really nice
i know they're going to be really hot
it's
your fault i'm ill yeah yeah
so but what's cool is we treat treat the
partner and and both get better
which is so cool we treat the sick
building person and and the other
partner gets better
so that's a possibility it's rare but
it's a possibility
so the other thing is when you're
exposed to those mycotoxins and your
sinuses start to go from a normal
healthy
sinu biome and your gut goes from a
normal healthy microbiome
now it becomes a pathogenic biofilm so
in almost every water damage building
there's bacterial endotoxins
as much as there are mycotoxins and in
every
water damage building sick person there
are
mold mycotoxins but there are also
bacterial endotoxins
that bacteria or that pathogenic biofilm
is
it's serving any bad character just in
case anyone listening doesn't know can
you
explain exactly what a biofilm is yeah i
would love to that's a good point
so a biofilm is a it's kind of like a
sludge it's a sticky
gooey film that will host
certain characters it's almost like a
decoy for them
so things that are normally growing in
our body
that are usually in a small amount like
candida is a good example
will overgrow and become
kind of start to act poorly and it will
find friends so if you've had a
a parasite infection or something that
really knocked out
your gut lining and your immune system
some of these kind of characters can
start to overgrow
and create this slimy matrix
that serves as a protection of these
bacteria and viruses and you know
parasites and
mold toxins fungi all those things so
there's
anything can grow in a biofilm usually a
biofilm is a pathogenic biofilm
meaning that and i should go back
biofilms in nature are more the rule
than the exception
so our my our microbiome is a biofilm
so if you're talking about microbiome as
a bacterial biofilm
that's a healthy health promoting
homeostatic
biofilm functional biofilm what happens
is that
now a pathogenic biofilm becomes more
sticky more gooey
more resistant to things moving in and
out it feeds itself
first before you versus a healthy
microbiome feeds you
and then they heart start to work
together
i think of it kind of like mad max you
know the guys that are all competing
but they are reliant on each other at
the same time but they're happy to gasp
on the other guy out like you know
whatever there goes another one
as long as i get to be the one in front
so that's kind of how they behave they
help each other out but they're in
competition
and so you have this um this kind of
film that is getting in the way of you
assimilating your nutrients and having a
healthy immune system
the bulk of our immune system is housed
in our gut
that's crazy for people to think about
like 70 percent of our immune system
resides inside of our gut so you know if
you have
bad actors there and they're acting
competitively and not
on behalf of the host then you're going
to be having
health problems did that explain it do
you think
yeah yeah i think i guess what how would
i
explain a biofilm well i i got into this
pretty intensely in 2017 i was like oh
my god maybe i just have a systemic
candida infection and that's the
cause of all my problems because maybe
it could be um
and it turned out i got retested after
they all meat diet and the all meat diet
knocked out the candida because it
doesn't feed it anything
but i did some research and found a
protocol that was antibacterial and
antifungal and i can't remember it it
used something called
fc cidal they were all herbs um
oregano oil and some something else um
and i fed it to my husband because i was
pregnant at the time and you can't do
that when you're pregnant
and it helped him it made him feel
terrible and then he felt better
afterwards
um so that was interesting but i guess i
would
describe a biofilm i don't know why i
went off on that tangent i guess i would
describe a biofilm as
you have like a single bacterium let's
just use bacteria as an example a single
bacterium
if you have a whole bunch of of them
sometimes they can act as one
organism and fungi will do the same
thing is you can have a single one but
if you have a whole host of them
they do something weird and can act as
one bigger
organism and that's kind of what a
biofilm can do
yeah i don't know if that description
was yeah i mean that's
good in the science term that's called
quorum sensing
yeah one you know fungi at the top of
the tube
can say hey guys i think she's getting
sick
this is a good time to have babies and
then the whole
film gets the message through that
matrix through that slime
it's like their internet you know yeah
it's creepy
there was there was one i don't remember
what type of mushroom it is
i remember learning about it in biology
but it was the same
it creeped me out i stopped eating
mushrooms after that because i was like
they know something
more than we're told but yeah they'd
they'd all get together
oh they'd go into spore form and they'd
just stay there until the environment
around them
changed and it was like decades in spore
form so they just live forever somehow
and then they could also clump together
and
move as one it was just and that was
yeah quorum sensing two degree and
it was just it was creepy and i stopped
eating mushrooms but um so biofilms are
scary and they're real
or you said they're healthy ones too i
never considered the healthy ones
yeah yeah but what's interesting is as i
treat
patients who have massive biofilm
invasion
and they start to peel it's i always
thought well maybe what we're doing is
we're dissolving the biofilm and then
the healthy microbiome can just kind of
come come to its place if we just
dissolve it almost like
you know i'm using soap and i'm just
dissolving grease it's not really how
that works with some of the really sick
people they actually will peel that
biofilm off
and they get a little bit and it's in
the gut they'll get a little yeah
bleeding and then you can see this like
mucousy
it was almost like a film like a snake
losing its skin kind of thing it's so
creepy but it's so wonderful it's so
rewarding you know of like
wow that was all of this this film that
was getting in the way of them absorbing
their food
is now gone you know so yeah your body
can
shed it like a skin as well so it's
that's so cool my target and i i don't
avoid i mean i have people avoid
mushrooms in the beginning
but i think you're right the mushrooms
do know stuff
and those those um
species that play along with mushrooms i
think are going to survive
whatever the planet has next in its plan
um so i use mushrooms at the very tail
end
for resiliency it's kind of that that i
call it
um i don't know if you know paul stamets
he's an amazing mic
yeah yeah he did the fungi project
recently um that i'm in
total awe of him and the work he's doing
with mushrooms and
he calls it michael remediation of soil
and i call it michael remediation of
immune systems so we do
the same thing you know that we need
those measures so
cool add it back at the very end to get
your resiliency back so that if you are
exposed to a water damage building like
it
one night in a hotel or something like
that because we we see that a lot people
say
oh i go somewhere for work it was moldy
in that
hotel room and now i've been sick for
two weeks so the micro remediation
using medicinal mushrooms at the very
end of treatment once we know we've
conquered the biofilm we've conquered
mold that gets people's resiliency back
so they can just have that night in the
hotel and not have to be
whacked maybe just a few symptoms but
they're
they're able to have resiliency against
that invasion
yeah cool so what kind of mushrooms
would be
medicinal mushrooms agaricon turkey tail
lion's mane all kinds of beautiful
beautiful mushrooms yeah so people are
like i know you're anti-mushroom i'm
like
no i'm not i'm actually a fan
i just don't want mold in my house you
know
oh okay that brings me back um
if somebody does have mold in their
house and it's in a wall
do they have to get rid of the whole
wall like how do you get rid of that
stuff
what if it's on a surface like how do
you clean that
well so if it's again using the building
experts
is so important because um you will have
people who are not trained that will
come in and say oh that's a pink mold
that can't be this or whatever yeah
every mold can take every color
it just depends on what it's eating whoa
i didn't know that yeah oh my god
you can't tell by looking at it and mold
is microscopic so if you are seeing it
it is already
a monster-sized city worth of mold
so that again using the building experts
in the gold standard is any affected
material needs to be cut out
so you have people that come in in the
you know the tyvek suits and the
respirators
and they close off the area so it
doesn't wow air with the rest of your
house
because otherwise you're going to just
infect the other parts of your house
so they plastic off the area they have
fans that
will pull air from that area out to the
outdoors so that it's
negative air meaning anytime there's
little zippers that they use
they open the zipper door to go into the
sick area
anytime they do that you don't want bad
mold to get poofed
out into your healthy part of your house
so remediation is its own
its own science but the gold standard is
every bit of sick material plus two feet
because it is microscopic
other areas could be affected yeah and
so that's why you have a lot of
landlords and occupational building
owners and
insurance companies trying to downplay
this
yeah because that's annoying calling me
crazy yeah
because they don't want to pay for it
it's a lot of disruption and hassle
and yeah but from all of the patients
that i've worked with
there there are some kind of rules of
thumb that i've created because right
now the going thought is
we'll just come in and fog it and then
it'll be fine or we'll come in and we'll
get an enzyme it'll be fine or we'll
seal it with a ceiling paint and none of
those are shown to be
effective against mycotoxins that might
work for spores
but if there are spores left in there
they're pumping out mycotoxins
so we need to really expand thinking
with remediation in buildings
and the certified inspectors the
certifications i gave you
they're thinking about mycotoxins
they're thinking about all the other
things that mold
creates cool
wow wow i'm glad we had this
conversation that's really interesting
and yeah being it's ridiculous that
people say this kind of thing doesn't
matter
because it makes way more sense that
something is making someone sick
then that person is just magically sick
for no reason
yeah right yeah the body has an innate
healing desire a drive to feel
well and so that might that immune
system might make
or they you know trying to heal
something might create damage in a body
but that's not your body doing you wrong
your body is trying to communicate
something
and so yeah i'm 100 with you that that
we are wired for health that's our
birthright
there's nothing if if your body is
complaining about something there's
something that
it's asking for yeah and people need to
really think about that because
sometimes they'll say oh well that's
just you know
i'm just a little bit older now that's
just normal everybody has that and a lot
of doctors will say yeah that's just a
normal symptom of
being 45 or something like that right
but if you have
if your body is telling you something
then there's probably something wrong
and you should look into that
it's not just your flaws yeah or they'll
say you know oh you have unresolved
trauma
maybe but you know being sick is
traumatizing so that idea that it's all
in your head
and oh that person i i've had this said
about a lot of my moltek patients that
had chronic disease
by their family members well they just
always have to have something wrong
yeah yeah they don't want to feel this
way people don't
want to feel like that so yeah i think
um keep investigating
no matter what if it's mold or anything
like that just keep liking
keep pushing so where can people find
your book
what should they google they can go to
amazon it's on amazon it's called break
the mold and then my website is
drkrista.com that's d-r-c-r-i-s-t-a
dot i'm on instagram facebook and i try
to do
like little public service announcement
things about mold every so often i'm
pretty sporadic with social media but i
try to get things out there as i learn
about it and of like oh hey did you guys
know this like this week i did citric
acid
because citric acid is some sensitivity
a lot of people have
and it's made synthesized from mold and
so there's that connection
you know like connecting things to mold
so yeah if people go to my website
there's a whole
video archive of all the little video
blogs that i've done through time and
they can learn a lot for free and then i
have a practitioner training course
on my courses tab that if there's a
practitioner listening that's like you
know what i think i need to learn about
this
they can do it in a weekend it's online
and um
i'm working on getting all the cme for
medical doctors i have all the
naturopathic cme stuff lined up but um
working on that this week so we'll see
cool
well yeah thank you thank you very much
for taking the time to come on
i learned a bunch and i think that was
that was fascinating
i think okay so i think we didn't
terrify people
i hope that people got the message i
hope we did terrify people
this is serious it is but you can treat
it
yeah yeah well people need to take some
of these problems seriously before
before they're sick like just
preventative would be nice
yeah yeah thank you thanks for helping
me get my message out i really
appreciate it
no problem i'm sure i'll talk to you
[Music]
soon
[Music]
you